it's 12 minutes right is every talked
woman joe namath wore number 12 for all
you gentle bands at home
Instagram want to jump on real quick
tomorrow in Los Angeles 7:00 to 9:00
p.m. shoe palace doing a little meet and
greet teaming up for my sneaker that's
coming out my collaboration sneaker
coming out in November with k-swiss so I
am teaming up with them to launch it at
shoe palace tomorrow are we switching
you don't have to but I like it for
tomorrow I mean they're so cool and
these are kind of my favorite pair that
they have okay looks like this morning
worried about you well I've got a couple
events
I'm fireside chatting will I am will
Osho Julie I'm very excited to be
fireside chatting you in a second
oh yeah I think don't don't like don't
be me ever
oh well now is my twelve minutes I've
got 12 minutes I'm gonna talk about I'm
going to be the mover of pillows great
[ __ ] everybody's trying to
communicate something and it's awfully
hard to penetrate if you think you're
going to be able to just talk in an
environment where the supply and demand
of talking has fundamentally shifted
these early is kind of the most
interesting moments four or five minutes
before
seven minutes before the keynote I get
into that weird zone where I just want
to describe what he'd be buddy it's the
weirdest thing I really get competitive
with the audience itself I want to give
it so much value that I turn into my
competitor such an interesting and so
anyway pretty interesting crowd a lot of
leaders from a lot of different sectors
here at Worlds so 12 minutes is super
short sometimes it takes me 12 months to
warm up as you know d-roc youtube you
guys know as you guys know usually you
guys all skip the first 12 minutes of
Akeno right because it's the the back
story so I'm going to get right into it
I'm my ronica not a zero to 60 speaker
on stage I am in rants I can go right
there but so this will be a good
challenge I'm excited about it then a
lot of friends in the audience a lot of
acquaintances should be an interesting
[ __ ] one other thing that has been
really on my mind when it comes to
entrepreneurship and the ones that are
winning and the ones that are losing and
the word is gratitude I am stunned by
people's ability to complain about dumb
[ __ ] I wish every one of you if I could
wish any fictional thing on you right
now I wish that your great-great-great
grandparents would come up be alive look
you dead in the face and say you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
of stuff but the fact I mean it's a most
micro-level because I'm actually going
macro here but at the most micro level
of entrepreneurship there was never a
day and age where you were under 30
getting four million dollar valuations
and funding on your idea respected in
society so much because the technology
shift all of a sudden 50 60 70 year olds
respect your point of view and yet we
find things to complain about even
though this is the single
disproportionate greatest fear ever to
be under 30 to build a business and it's
not even close
and so we complain about things like
Facebook and Instagram change their
algorithm like that but like let me just
save everybody a little time
if you mean somebody who's complaining
their business is in trouble because
Facebook Instagram changed their
algorithm that person [ __ ] lost their
done the one thing I've lost that I'm
now reconnected with over the last 12
months that I implore everybody here
gets really connected with is that
entrepreneurship changes every day
the market changes every day things
happen every day
entrepreneurship sucks I know it's cool
but let me tell you entrepreneurship is
lonely a [ __ ] one thing we don't talk
about in this group of friends we like
to talk about all the good [ __ ] we're
not talking about the depression and
suicide that so many of our friends are
going through because it's the first
time they've actually lost because
school is a big game entrepreneurship is
you're playing against the market and
the market doesn't give a [ __ ] what your
grandfather did and so we need to really
really start understanding that the
number one trait of a number one is the
ability to get punched in the mouth to
face the stomach over and over and over
and over again
I eat [ __ ] for a living
and your ability in this room if you
aspire continue to be an entrepreneur
your ability to eat [ __ ] is the quickest
indicator of where you end up because it
moves it changes and we're treating it
like this awesome lifestyle thing
putting [ __ ] [ __ ] photos on
Instagram like it's so [ __ ] rad my
friends entrepreneurship is not
Coachella they're like a problem Hey
really good how are you yeah yeah yeah
all right so what's your favorite thing
about this the people you know I think I
think there's so many friends and
acquaintances that come to this event
that are in my social graph that I don't
get to spend time with because
everybody's kind of busy the people that
I deem friend in solids acquaintances
are the ones I had barely see because
they're hustling as well so just being
able to run into that and then and then
the other hundred people 30 people 17
people that I get to run into introduce
myself get to know them so I think of it
as like the depth and the width of
worlds that a lot of events don't
provide for me so you know depth being
that fourth or fifth time I get to have
a conversation with somebody that's in
my circle but with that you know so many
times and it's already happen I've been
here just a few hours and last time
gaining context with that first
introduction to new people that I'll
know forever I like that you say change
your friend group how do you get started
on that first living in a place like LA
you know you harass the interactive how
do you what the firstnet is one of the
first times I've ever talked about it on
stage today so I'm still kind of
developing this thought but I've been
giving a lot of thought to how fortunate
I am I think a lot of people talk about
luck and when you're somebody like me
like you work a lot and things of that
nature it's hard to accept luck but
there's no question things like being
able to immigrant out of the Soviet
Union or having a mother that is so
insanely amazing you know I didn't
control that that was given to me and so
one of things I've been thinking a lot
about is well what happens when you're
25 you hear one of my clips you're
somebody else and you're like wait
that's true
my mom stinks or like my family
environment was bad or maybe I was true
let me go another way maybe I was so
privileged that I don't have hunger if
you now are self-aware or deploying new
thoughts and you understand some truths
what can you do about it the only thing
that I believe in is you can't fake
environment
you can't fake environment so if you
gather yourself with people who are from
a certain cloth or have a certain hunger
or have a certain point of view very
quickly that rubs off on you and I think
what people struggle with is when they
want to evolve they want to stay
tried-and-true to their friends and
that's a very difficult bridge of
selling out in both directions I think
the cliche one is you come from not that
much and you want to move up that's the
one that most people think when they
hear this but I'll tell you that
probably I'm probably giving more advice
to kids that grew up with privilege to
go and like live in reality because
that's the only way they can offset and
that's super hard too because breaking
your patterns is extremely difficult and
but if you're unhappy with your
situation you've got to change a pattern
much like a diet like if you're not
happy with where you're at you've got to
change your patterns in a hardcore way I
just believe in that in life and that is
just not a conversation that people are
having it's not a very politically
correct conversation mmm I think I'll be
historically correct so I'm willing to
take the short-term pushback for the
long-term success
you change your library what people make
a mistake is they make to a tea being a
salesperson they want to start a cute
candle company but then they buy a house
and have all this overhead and they
[ __ ] feed their own thing and they
never go make the handout if you know
you want to do something else and you're
good at this
save your [ __ ] money and then when
you jump into the pool go [ __ ] rent a
[ __ ] and give yourself that two
years to see if you can do it and then
you live with no regret because you can
always go back never want to wake up
thing with it because you can always go
back to the thing that you're good at
that makes you money that you don't love
you can always go back to that there's
all these people looking for salespeople
got it super productive day will be a
nice little clean edit for you d rock
nice tight day got a workout now I got
to speak those in take care of your body
just don't read a good strategy and a
couple meetings for tonight
reload for tomorrow just got done with
it incredible I don't know if you film
this you rock probably did that's how
you roll but I saw you bullshitting with
Tyler so maybe you didn't but if you did
just got done with an incredible
recruitment call we're super [ __ ]
passionate about you I listen to be very
frank I've already won because of this
phone call right either you go with us
have we dominate or I get to make fun of
you at the Pro Bowl in nine years not
coming with us this Danish sports thing
is so funny it's amazing how how
passionate I am - these kids are making
such funny decisions it's like us and
not us it's like you know in the agency
world in the wine world like us versus
the rest was close enough that it didn't
feel like devastating these kids are God
I really hope they going us anyway
nothing the less good day and I hope
everybody's in that we're in the dog
days of summer this is when a separation
in the marketplace happens you drink and
rose' on the beach or aren't you
cool
[Music]